[dramatic music]
I set out to find someone
to whom I could serve
one or both
of my knuckle sandwiches,
but everywhere I went,
perfectly decent people
were going about their lives,
failing to provoke
a righteous pummeling.
[horn honks]
[exhales deeply]
♪ ♪
Aha.
Well, this man just cut me
in line for the ATM.
Now I have a reason to start
a bare-knuckle brawl.
Ahem.
Excuse me.
- I was next for that ATM.
- Just--
- [grunts]
- Oh, [bleep]! Wow, wow.
That really hurts.
That's something
I had not considered,
how much it hurts me
to punch somebody.
Obviously it hurts when
you're getting punched, but--
Ah!
[gunshots]
- Oh, [bleep]! [bleep]!
[people screaming]
[bleep]! [bleep]!
Oh.
- Yeah, I just shot somebody.
- [bleep], [bleep]!
- Why?
- I don't know.
I got scared, okay?
Just shut up for a minute.
Let me think, Mom.
[siren wails]
- Yes, it happened again, okay?
Forrest?
You getting this?
[dramatic music]
(Forrest)
Having been shot three times
with a gun,
I underwent emergency surgery
to save my life.
The extreme blood loss
caused me to slip into a coma,
which I can only describe
as restful.
Review footage allows me
to appreciate
that I received many visitors
in my unconscious state,
including my producer, Grant,
and my executive assistant,
Lucille,
who struggled to put
their concern into words.
What if we, like,
put a pillow on his face
and pretended
we were smothering him?
I mean, we would be
smothering him,
but we'd take the pillow off,
obviously.
Would he fight for life?
(Forrest)
My intern, Josh, stopped by
with his new girlfriend, Tina.
They behaved regrettably
during their visit.
I was touched to see that even
my estranged ex-wife stopped by,
and despite the presence
of this show's cameras,
almost entered my room.
But most frequently by my side
were my father
and my nurse, Marisa,
who was holding my hand
when I miraculously emerged
from two months in a coma.
Excuse me,
I was next for that ATM.
- Bicycle.
- Very good.
(Forrest)
Marisa stayed by my side
down the long road
to recovery.
Conspiracy.
Bridge.
(Forrest)
And I'm happy to say that
we struck up
a bit of a romance.
(Marisa)
That's good.
(Forrest)
Learning to walk again was
one of the greatest challenges
of my life,
but Marisa's cheerful,
nurturing presence
gave me something
to walk toward.
There you are.
(Forrest)
Over time, we shared
our fears and struggles,
and I vowed to get
strong enough
to hold Marisa up
as she now held me,
or as she put it one day
during therapy...
I heal you,
you heal me.